hey um i i've got an uh i've got an
interesting voicemail to play for you
you can leave a voicemail anytime at 219
to david p it's about a wacky
congresswoman lauren bobert
and uh her education and or lack thereof
and
there's a few things here i want to talk
about so let's listen uh good evening
david
uh my name is ray i'm calling in regards
to congresswoman bobart
uh i was doing some research on her and
i stumbled across the fact that
she received her ged not her high school
diploma
in may of 2020 right yet her office
and her people have not confirmed nor
denied
that she received it nor if she even
has one so there seems to be something
not
right with that um based on the fact
that if she had received it in may
you know they would have to basically
just say yeah this happened and
that's okay but they seem to not even
want to address it which could mean
to me possibly that she doesn't even
have one
so maybe that's something that our
viewers can dig deeper into this
and uh and just find out what's going on
with this person
because she she's totally unfit to be in
congress so
yeah now so listen a lot of what the
caller says is correct lauren bobert is
completely unfit to be in congress
it's not because she doesn't have a high
school diploma or college education
necessarily she's unfit because
she's a radical insurrectionist and part
of the problem we're trying to solve
rather than any possible solution now in
terms of the ged stuff the caller is
correct
it is asserted that lauren bobert got
her ged that the story of lauren
beaubert is something like and i'm
paraphrasing here
she was in high school but she dropped
out to work at mcdonald's
i don't remember if it was to support
her family or what what the the
reasoning
was and then she later went back and got
her ged
uh a few months ago reportedly getting
it in may of 2020.
i have no idea it's i've not seen what
we might call proof that she really got
her ged
she may have it she may not but but
here's the thing this is not about
education
shaming lauren beaubert is an ignorant
person regardless of what kind of degree
she has
a year ago i met someone with a phd in
biology
who maybe when it came to biology was an
absolute genius but was a complete and
total idiot
when it came to political science
economics
cultural issues sociology i mean it was
just
i i felt like i was talking to someone
who who uh seemed to lack education
altogether so you know when it comes to
biology maybe this person was great
maybe not
having or not having a ged high school
diploma college degree master's degree
phd it is not proof that you are or
aren't fit
to be an elected official um the sad
truth is that whether lauren beaubert
does or doesn't have a ged
she is not someone that should be
involved in making law or leading the
country whatsoever now on the other hand
bill gates dropped out of college
he's more than well qualified to be a
member of congress or senator
he understands the scientific method he
understands how to think about problems
he understands how to manage people and
projects
and on and on and on and so for me the
problem is that for some of these
folks the lack of education has become
sort of a point of pride where voters
are
drawn to someone because they've fallen
for this idea that higher education is a
liberal indoctrination conspiracy theory
thing and they they seem to think that
by electing someone who's not gone to
college
that they're owning the libs in some way
i think it's important that we on the
left
don't focus on education shaming there
are plenty of people
without significant degrees of formal
education
who are very smart and would be great
leaders for this country
and that would be fantastic and as i've
said before in general we should be
diversifying the types of folks that
represent us we don't want just
former lawyers and former ceos
and career politicians i would love
teachers
i would love met people from science i
would like people for you know
on and on and on but the idea of going
to people without formal education
merely because you think education is
liberal indoctrination is a problem
and so uh if if lauren beaubert is lying
about her ged
that's a major problem if lauren
beaubert is
unfit to be a member of congress because
of her ideas and
and the fact that she brings no
knowledge whatsoever about policy and
that's the case
she shouldn't be in the house of
representatives and she shouldn't but i
think we need to look more deeply
much the same way as trump as a can
trump if trump had run as a democrat
he'd have had no shot of winning the
primary
and trumpism wouldn't be what it is
trumpism is what it is
because trump ran as a republican and
the republican electorate
fell for it slash liked it slash was
drawn to it partially to quote own the
libs as they would often say
um and so a lot of the problem is
the electorate the electorate that sees
someone as incompetent as lauren bobert
and regardless of her formal education
level says let's choose her
that's what we need to solve that's a
bigger cultural issue
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about the republican
counteroffer to biden's covet 19 bill
and much much more become a member and
get instant access
at joinpakman.com